hey wassup my name's Samuel Leeds I'm a
property investor and on Sunday this is
where you ask questions and I answer
your questions last Sunday I had some
really interesting questions I've got a
quick look through and I'm gonna answer
last week's questions while you're
listening to me answer last week's
questions I want you to ask your
questions and if I answer one of your
questions let me know let me know what
you thought my answer please do don't
forget to smash that like button also if
you're not already subscribed to the
channel turn on the notification bow
subscribe do that right now and let's
see what we've got all right so well
though did you subscribe I hope you did
subscribe right now cool thank you thank
you
okay sound Stubbings since Samuel I've
got an urgent question how could I not
answer an urgent question Sam he says
I'm doing the rent to SI joint venture
okay cool all I have done is invested
money I'm not doing any management or
have anything to do with the property
just put down 50% of the money and I get
50% of the profits I do not have my own
company do I still need an accountant to
calculate tax for me I'm doing the ABC
now I've got to figure out the XYZ
thanks in advance
great job Sam sounds interesting yeah
you'll need obviously to pay tax on your
money so the profit that you're getting
in each month from this from this deal
you're gonna need to pay tax on profit
so my advice would be probably to get an
accountant because they're going to be
able to make sure that you're paying tax
and you're paying right on that and not
paying too much also any make sure that
you're your business partner is keeping
all the receipts and claiming expenses
on stuff and you are as well but yeah
good job good job
like it Sam Jones lots of Sam's today
Sam Jones says if you're a first-time
buyer and under the age of 18 would you
recommend buying the property is a
limited company or in a family members
name to be honest Sam if you're under 18
I just say congratulations for buying a
property at all should you do it in a
limited company or a family member's
name or you could do it in both because
you could set up a company in a family
member's name and then you could buy the
property through that company and beard
and you could be a director on that
company listen I don't know you or your
situation or the house so I can't give
tax advice but speak to an accountant
and work out the best way to do it but
good job respect
okay Jake booth hi Samuel I stumbled
upon your channel today nice I hope
you're still watching I hope you
subscribe because that's the thing if
you don't subscribe to the channel I
might be talking about you and reading
your questions and you don't even know
so subscribe subscribe subscribe I'll be
going for your videos I'm interested in
investing in property
awesome I'm 20 years old great I own
zero properties and I'm a university
student my first question is what advice
would you give to a beginner who is just
starting out my second question is I've
seen a few of your videos in which you
reference Lease Option agreements my
question is how would I find sellers
willing to follow that agreement and
given the current situation in regards
to Cove it would many sellers be willing
to use this agreement due to wanting
guaranteed income correct me if I'm
wrong on my understanding of lease
options as I previously said I'm new to
all this thanks Jake great long question
there's two questions first question was
what can you do to get started my advice
if you're getting started would be to
immerse yourself in my youtube videos
get books get CDs get podcasts find
other property investors you want
success buddies find people that are
also on a similar journey surround
yourself with them who you surround
yourself with is who you become and then
figure out your strategy plan it do it
review it plan on what you're gonna do
not in the next five years say what do I
want to achieve in the next five months
then go and do it and then in five
months look back at what you did and
review what you can do differently what
you could have done better set big goals
but not so big that they're unattainable
and set goals for short period of time
so that would be a little bit of advice
for starting out I hope that helps Lease
Option agreements yeah now's the time
for Lease Option agreements because now
people are very worried people are
dropping into negative equity it's
absolute perfect time so good luck and
knock yourself out let me know if I can
be of any help I'll be - hi Samuel of
evideos could really do your expertise
I'm looking to buy a house for my
parents to them rent to them as an
investment for myself but also to give
them some security I have my own place
so we won't be living there I heard
mixed views on the best way to do it
I've read about be regulated by to let
mortgages what would you recommend is
the best most cost-effective way to make
this work okay if I'm really honest with
you the best way to do this is to not do
it at all
it's a terrible plan now I appreciate
that you're trying to do to help your
parents
some security but whenever I've seen
this happen which is buying an
investment property but trying to kill
two birds it always fails miserably on
the dude they've come into the lease
option agreement on your house when your
parents move out and now you're stuck
with a property that you bought for your
parents and actually the investment
property it doesn't work to you good
you're better off to buy property with
the sole intention of making money and
then with that money if you want to use
that money to help your parents no
problem but trying to kill two birds
with buying property investment like I
just don't think it works so I wouldn't
do it all so it's probably not what you
went to here feel free to follow up with
the question but that's my hand on heart
advice as if advising your brother Mars
owl money
Samuel what area in the UK would you
focus on investing in 2000 2021 Thanks
it just depends on your strategy like
you want to invest in an area that you
know and you want to invest in an area
that works for your strategy if your
deal packaging or if you're doing lease
option agreement so it might be
different to if you're doing HMOs too if
you're doing a single wall that's good
if you do imbibe refurbish refinances so
find an area figure it out find a
strategy and crush that area but which
area dude you can you can make money in
any area like you just got to pick the
right strategy in that area so I can't
give you if there was a one magic golden
area in the whole of the country or the
whole of the world very quickly it would
become not very good because everyone
would just jump there and then
oversaturation would happen so it's
always changing as well so so I can't be
more specific
gaghe and deep Gaghan deep seen my time
you hope you will have a question
regarding an area in Birmingham where I
have just bought a property in which
article four is due to start in June
congratulations from buying a property
article four is to start in June in this
year I'm in the process of turning it to
a five Ben hates em oh but I was
wondering if I can get some clarity on
something does article four affect the
declaring your property as a HMO to the
planning depth or does it mean that you
need to have a license and then that the
number of tenants okay don't get mixed
up between article four and planning
permission and licensing because they're
two separate things
article four
in June you should get that property
rented out and you should keep hold of
the contracts with your tenants what
that will mean is it'll mean that the
contracts that you've got the ast
contracts with your tenants will be your
evidence your proof that you have been
renting this out as a HMO prior to June
we're now in may get that rented fast
keep the AST contracts show the AST
contracts to the planning department and
then you will be granted automatic
grandfather rights automatic planning
permission on the property for free of
charge you'd have to do anything so
that's how it works licensing is a
separate thing you will need a license
you will need a license I'd get that I'd
be on that now because if you don't get
tenants in that property into our next
month you won't be able to ever get
tenants in that property ever because
you're only because if it hasn't got
planning permission already which it
doesn't have all the sounds of it you
only planning to turn it into a hey CH
mo and that's that's not going to happen
you won't be able to get it so you need
to rent that fast you can rent a proc
his a bit of good news for you as well
gagin deep you don't need to wait until
given a license before you can rent out
property as a HMA all you need to do is
you need to apply for a license as soon
as you've applied for a license you can
then rent the property out because it
can take ages for them to get back to
you so you need to apply for a license
online you need to then immediately
create an advert on spare room calm
spare room doctor at UK rent the rooms
out fast even if you rent them for cheap
get AST contracts with the tenants fast
then take those contracts and show them
to plan department that's what you need
to do if you need any help let me know
but you've got to do that otherwise
you'll have massively missed an
opportunity so I'm glad that you asked
your question
okay Benji said hi Sam you love the
videos I'm expanding on the point of
buying in your own name versus buying in
a limited company could you explain a
bit on the process of buying within a
limited company and the tax benefits you
get I'm thinking of buying my first
thing all that but the change in section
24 we'll make it a break even better
best exercise Ben
it will make you a break even at best
exercise you just find the wrong houses
you don't want to buy a house and have
it a break even you're looking at the
wrong houses man sexually 24 means that
buy to let mortgage payments are tax
deductible that's all it means
so if you buy through a limited company
that doesn't apply if you buy through a
limited company then the mortgage
payments are tax deductible but you
shouldn't be buying anything right now
because you don't know what to buy
because you're talking about break even
that's ridiculous I'd be fat I've been
robbed rather than thinking about the
tax it's good to save money yeah save
money on tax but before you think about
that you've got to think about how
you're gonna make money they're gonna
make a lot of money in property and then
when you do that then you can think okay
this is my strategy now that'll work out
if I should buy through a company or no
and you probably should hope that helps
ma'am god bless you brother okay Karen
Karen what do you think of the BRR in
2020 would you look for a HMO or
buy-to-let okay if you're doing the
buyer refurbished refinance strategy in
2020 you can either do it on a HMO or on
a by Gillette property depends on your
experience I would say if I do it on a
HMO cuz you're going to make more money
but if you if you don't even understand
the buyer refurbished refine that
strategy you're just starting out it
might be worth doing it on a normal
family home like a single layer to get
the experience of the by the refurb in
that we finance and then once you've got
the experience then go and do it on a
HMO property because if you ever done a
BRR and you haven't got HMO and you're
doing everything all together at once
you can get pretty daunting and pretty
stressful so it depends on your
experience but you want to aim
ultimately BRR our HMO boom had the
helps what else we got
Melanie Melanie she says ah thanks for
sharing my post and answering the
question that's you're welcome that's
what I do it also if you if you say
something nice to me on Instagram if you
send me a nice diet message or if used
to do something or if you set shares to
me on your story or if I see stuff going
around positive I'm gonna share the heck
out of it that's how I roll I share
positivity what do you think about this
so I'm currently looking at this one bed
flat based in Liverpool l3 postcode
which is four hundred twenty one squared
feet price is 126 thousand service
charge 877 grammar 20
six do these figures sound realistic to
you ast forecast rental yields 725 per
month serviced accommodation rental
yield one thousand four hundred and
ninety pound per month five-year growth
estimate based on one hundred thirty
thousand pound completion 161 Melanie
yeah it looks decent I think that if it
as a single let if you if you can't get
it a serviced accommodation if there's a
restrict I'd check the restrictions
check the head leases and stuff like
that but if you can do it serviced
accommodation and you've checked the
demand in the area then I think it'll be
really good as a normal single layer
it's not great at all and you can't rely
on a couple of depreciation
I mean that is just completely
speculative really it's very likely but
it's Liverpool is going up a lot at the
moment but it's very speculative we
don't know what's going to happen but if
you can get that if you can make sure
that the head lease is good and you can
rent that out on sa service
accommodation it's a good deal if you
can't then it's not great but I guess
it's always a it's not a terrible exit
plan so yeah interesting good stuff well
done hey guys if you enjoyed this video
if you're finding this valuable smash
the friggin like button and if you
haven't subscribed yet subscribe before
I can't find you okay um our afro afro
promotions hey Samuel what's the minimum
requirement of bathrooms needed in a
four or five bed house if you're renting
is hmm so the minimum requirement you
don't need more than one bathroom
legally but you probably should if
you've got a four if you've got a four
bed hey chairman you only need one
bathroom but the more bathrooms the
better on Suites are beginning to get a
bit more popular now so I'd probably say
if it's a four bed you can get away with
one bathroom just about five beds you're
gonna want to or at least one bathroom
and an ensuite at least okay how can I
convince my parents to let me focus on
property instead of going to university
okay first thing is you forget what your
parents want this is about what you want
this is your life you cannot live your
life trying to please anybody else and
other people's approval or disapproval
or somebody's not going to not going to
control your happiness so there is it's
going to control your happiness is if
you do what someone else wants you to do
your whole life and then you think what
am i doing I don't want to do this go to
university if you want to go to
university if you want to get a job
doing something that requires universe
go to university if you don't don't do
it please your freaking parents don't do
that that's not why would you spend four
years if you were live doing something
it's a complete waste if you don't want
to do it just man up and have that
conversation with your folks
I don't want to go to you and guess what
I'm not doing it you've forced to go to
school from the age of 4 to 16 after
that is your choice is it 18 now oh man
but as soon as it's your choice it's
your choice then do I'm guilt or trying
to please anybody believe me you'll
please the more when you become a
property millionaire and start buying
them stuff okay what we got unfinished
mish something I've got 10 grand free
cash I don't know what you mean by free
Oh free is in available fire and got you
that I want to invest my friends have
all advised me to buy into the stock
market as the stock markets and now Half
Price and my family have invested
property I don't have any shares within
the stock market what would you do in my
situation I do agree with my friends the
stocks are extremely low because of
kovat thanks Adam Adam what I'd say is
I'd say you need to get a grip in you
need to figure out what's best for you
and you need to figure out what's
profitable like it doesn't matter what
your mom's saying it doesn't matter what
I'm saying it doesn't matter what your
friends are saying what matters is what
do you know like 10 grand is not that
much money okay but if you if you know
what to do with it and you're smart you
could you could scale it a large company
from ten thousand pounds so but you've
got to have that knowledge I say you'd
be better off investing the whole ten
thousand in yourself I'm gonna get a
mentor I'm gonna get trained I'm gonna
get good I'm gonna spend that on petrol
money driving around to conferences and
seminars I'm gonna get good because it's
not about the money it's ultimately
about what you know so I don't know that
much about the stock market
I don't invest in the stock market I
invest in property so if I was going to
invest hang around I would put it in
property that's what I do but before you
put in money anywhere you want to put it
in yourself property will not make you
rich
stocks will not make you rich what make
you rich is you utilizing it properly
and you know what you're doing with what
you do it so that's that's my advice
hope that helps okay what we got I'll
just give you one or two more I think
Steven Santos Sammy on 17 young people
on today good
for you man I was 17 miles dying I'm
dying to get into property no he says
I'm trying you've got to be dying though
you've got to be dying to get into
property you've got to be prepared to do
whatever it takes
you're gonna you've got to you got to
let your let your pride die you've got
to let your fear of rejection die you've
got to be dying
Yusei trying trying won't get you
successful like you Warriors and
champions don't try to do anything they
choose to do or choose not to so you got
to be prepared to do whatever it takes
that's my first point but go on I'll
read the rest to you question we've
little money I was wondering if I could
sauce deals without going through legal
matters such as registering with a
property Ombudsman or having indemnity
insurance if not would passing on on a
source to another source to be a good
idea also could you briefly go over what
sort of contracts you'd have to sign as
a deal sorcerer Stephen yes you don't
need any money you don't need any
insurance you don't need anything and
you can find a deal and you can pass it
to a deal sorcerer and they can sell it
to their list and to their investors all
you do is find the deal and then you can
split whatever you want to split with
that deal you can make one thousand
pounds in the next week if you just go
out and do that and you don't need
anything people will tell you just
insurance and you know you do not are
you to be 18 no you do not yes you can
do that like and deal sourcing is one of
the most powerful strategies there is
right now because people are putting a
lot of cash cash investors into real
estate in the UK right now and they
don't have time to go and find deals
they need a 17 year old kid who's being
trained who's smart who's got courage
who can negotiate who can speak on the
phone you can sift through right moves
who can put forward lots of offers who
can catch a bus or a train and go and
view things in the rain and then present
it to them and then they'll go I like
that or I don't like that and if they
like that tell pay you and if you
haven't got insurance and you haven't
got those investors and you haven't got
any of that business set up then work
alongside an existing sorcerer and bring
them the deals and say I'm not gonna
pass you the deal it's just bleep with
me it's called code deal sourcing you
can do that
Alex hi Samuel if you were to go back to
your teenage years what would you what
would you did to start do you think
selling leads or deals is a good
risk-free way to start
I would sell deals I didn't figure out
deal sourcing until I was 24 then I sold
hundreds of deals I've made hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
pounds just by finding a deal passing on
deal sourcing so that's how I'd start
that's a great strategy
anyone can do it guess what when you get
the best deals what are you gonna do
you're gonna bind yourself but you don't
have the money to buy on yourself so
what do you do then you don't have the
money but you now have know lots of
investors so you're gonna ask one of
your investors to collaborate with you
to give you the money and if they don't
want to give you the money you're gonna
say I got this great deal you got the
money I found it
let's do a joint venture very possible
alright shadow shadow crooks are you
worried about house prices dropping
substantially in the coming recession
given the property investing given that
in property investing you're highly
leveraged no I'm not worried and now I'm
not highly leveraged you just made a
wrong assumption ah I wish I was more
highly leveraged I can't get my cash out
right now fast enough I've got so many
houses that are unencumbered with no
mortgage that I wish had a mortgage on
them because I wish I had the money
because I'm seeing so many opportunities
and so many deals right now I wish I had
the money to put in them but I'm just
trying to pull my money out first I'm
not I'm not highly leveraged I should be
more highly leveraged than I am so wrong
assumption bro but your question was am
I worried about him dropping no because
if they drop they're gonna go back up
again I'm not planning on selling
anytime soon
well I'm saying some of them are smaller
deals but why would I be worried about
dropping if I'm getting cash flow I
don't care about me dropping or not it's
paper money if I've got a house worth
three hundred grand and then in six
months time he drops to 200 grand
unless I sell that house it doesn't
matter even if it dips into negative
equity my mortgage doesn't change my
mortgage payments are the same doesn't
matter
and if house prices drop what's going to
happen to rents they'll go up because
because what happens is when property
prices drop down
people are not buying properties that
much because they can't afford it cuz
there's a recession more people are
renting and where more people are
renting that means my rents go up which
is I'm just getting more cash flow so
I'm not worried in the slightest and
neither should you be you should be
excited if you haven't got any
properties right now if you just got one
or two and you're looking at growing
your portfolio you should be praying
that house prices drop because then it
means that they're all affordable for
you the investor to come and buy them
and the rent the rent ain't going to
drop so you should be crossing your
fingers that house prices are going to
drop right now and so should I all right
last question Dan Jason hi Samuel do you
think you'll be running the crash
courses and the others when the virus is
behind us been saving for like a year
dan I hope so I hope I'll be back back
running the crash courses and stuff I
want to we haven't we haven't set any
dates yet I'm just right now I'm just
focusing on my business I'm gonna
continue putting out content and
continuing doing YouTube videos and
continuing helping people I'm really
focusing on my business my property
business on my properties
yeah I'm sure man when we come out a lot
down 100% I want to start doing crash
courses again and I know there's a
massive demand I've I've put the crash
course online you know we've had
thousands of people signed up for the
crash course online you can do it you
can get access to it for one pound go on
Samuel Samuel 365.com I'll leave a link
in the description and it's a 95-pound
per month subscription but you can
cancel at any time one pound for a 14
day trial and in that 14 days you can do
the whole crash course online and it's
amazing also is well I'm quitting
there's so much free stuff that's what I
love it when you guys subscribe and like
and share because I I put out so much
for free most of the stuff I put out I
put out for free yeah there's some
there's some advanced stuff I'm running
a webinar on Tuesday this week and I'm
teaching deal sourcing I'm teaching how
to package and sell deals how to build
your investor list how to get deals how
to become compliant how to get a good
reputation and how to sell how to sell
I suppose people's problem I'm teaching
that on a webinar a live webinar I'm
teaching on Tuesday I'll leave a link
again in the description below if you're
watching this now you want to package
and sell deals you want to make cash
flow right now
you need to learn to sell abuse and I'm
teaching that on Tuesday night
so subscribe book on the crash course
sign up for Samuel 365 and do the crash
course sign up for the register the link
for the webinar and we'll do that on
Tuesday Tuesday evening and I'll just
continue pumping out stuff continue
seeing you guys succeed I'm loving these
comments I'm literally seeing so many
people in the comments there's a lot of
young people saying I'm wanting to get
into it there's also a lot of people
saying I've got one house I got a couple
deals I've got this deal I've got that
deal good job for getting deals keep it
going be a deal sourcing machine
subscribe smash like drop a question
below and I'll see you next time